finally tonight creating quite the buzz
on social media is the fashion attire
from the inauguration
i'm sure that you've seen it all over
facebook all over twitter
right brian it's all over the place it
is comprehensively across all social
media vermont senator bernie sanders
wore a beige parka
and a pair of those wool mittens well it
all led to a photo of him sitting across
like
it that went viral on social media he
was then photoshopped in different
places there's a sweet story behind the
mittens
school teacher jen ellis gave him them
back in 2016.
people wear things from
famous fashion designers to the
inauguration and there was bernie
wearing mittens that i made
you know in my craft room with a sewing
machine that
my mother gave to me when i was 12. ella
says she's had more than 6 000 requests
for a pair of remittance denise my
favorite is when he's leaning on bruce
springsteen's shoulder on the board to
run album cover
oh god i haven't seen that one it's on
your social
great stuff bernie